تنقل ميسي بين الانديه في سن السادسه
منظما الى نيوز وهو نادن محلي موجود في
روزاريو حيث لعب اكثر من ست سنوات مطورا
مهاراته اكثر ومكتسبا قدرا اكبر من الخبره
واحاط نفسه بلاعبين مستقبليين محتملين
بينما هو في نادي نيوز كان ميسي يظهر اي
نوع من اللاعبين سيصبح خلال سنواته الست
في النادي قام بتسجيل قرابه 500 هدف واصبح
عضوا في مجموعه السبعه والثمانين التي
سميت كذلك لانه كان شبه مستحيلا التغلب
على اولئك الناشئين منذ ولادتهم عام 87
احبت الجماهير مشاهده لعب ميسي فلم يكن
يسجل الاهداف بانتظام فحسب بل يقدم ايضا
حيالا كرويه في الاستراحه فتى مشاكس يركض
بخطوات قصيره وسريعه خلف الكره كان يمر
بين اللاعبين بسهوله تامه
بدت مسيرته في كره القدم موشكه على
الازدهار لكن في سن الحاديه عشره تلقى
ميسي خبرا كان سيعرض مسيرته في كره القدم
للخطر
[موسيقى]
انه لاعب كره قدم استثنائي الافضل في
مجموعته يعرف نادي نيوز اولد بويز ذلك عنه
لكن يمر الاطفال في سن النمو وينتشق
الصغار طولا ولا يمكنك التنبؤ بتلك السن
لكن ذلك لم يحدث مع ليونيل ميسي مشكله
ميسي انه باتا واضحا في سن الحاديه عشره
انه لا ينمو بتاتا وتم تشخيص حاله نقص
هرمون النمو لديه والتي عرضت مستقبله كله
للشكوك
وكان الفتى الصغير مريضا ما شكل عيبا
معينا بالنسبه اليه
وكان يخشى الا يهتم به بسبب ذلك
اراد ان يكون طويلا سواء من الناحيه
الجماليه ام من الناحيه الرياضيه فقد كان
شغوفا بكره القدم
كان يريد ان يكبر ليلعب كره القدم وكان
يخشى ان يرفضوه بسبب ذلك قلت له لا تقلق
ستصبح اطول من مارادونا لا اعلم ان كنت
ستصبح افضل منه لكنك ستصبح اطول بالتاكيد
خضع ميسي للعلاج رغم انه كلف عائلته قرابه
1000 دولار شهريا خلال معالجته وواصل
اللعب لنادي نيوز مقدما اداء رائعا كل
اسبوع لكن كانت الامور توشيك على التحول
بالنسبه الى ميسي اليافع كان ميسي في تلك
المرحله لا يزال مع نيوز يحاول معالجه
مشكله ما اذا كان سينمو كفايه ليصبح لاعب
كره قدم قال بعضهم انه لن يصل الى شيء كان
فريق مهتما بضمه ايضا لكن عائلته نظرت
ابعد من ذلك وكانت لها علاقات في كتالونيا
في اسبانيا وفي سن 13 حظي بفتره تجريبيه
مع برشلونه النادي الذي اراد ضمه الى
صفوفه مباشره سافرت عائله ميسي الى
برشلونه بعد تلقيهم الموافقه على الفتره
التجريبيه وسريعا خلال تلك الفتره
التجريبيه اراد مدير فريق برشلونه الاول
تشارلياك ضمه حين راى فيه موهبه لكن للاسف
بسبب سنه الصغيره وحقيقه انه لم يكن من
كتالونيا تردد مجلس الاداره في ضمه الى
النادي اذا حاولت تخيل الناشئين في سن 13
خلال مرحله تجريبيه مع برشلونه فليسوا
اطفالا عاديين نلعب معهم في الشارع بل هم
صفوه الصفوه لكن حين دخل ميسي في تلك
الفتره التجريبيه لم يكن لدى اي احد في
برشلونه اوهام على الاطلاق لقد كان صفوه
ذلك النادي المميز والخاص جدا وعليهم ضمه
اليهم